what is information dump is it a good
thing a bad thing oh well this is the
question of how do you get information
to the audience people want to know why
people on screen are doing what they're
doing in order to communicate that you
have to give them background information
get us let us know what the
circumstances of the movie are and the
question is how do you how do you convey
that information and the human mind
doesn't respond well to raw information
that's just dumped on them
we need a context to remember it and a
great example is the recipe I don't know
of anybody who gets a recipe because
they're cooking something reads it once
and then goes and does it it's a
constant what do I need now what do I
need no yeah that's because it there's
no context for that information it's
just dumped on you in order for us to
get accepted information and take it in
we need it needs to be embedded in
something else and it needs to be in
little bits and pieces and so we talked
about exposition strategies which I will
be familiar to some people that people
have written about this but it's giving
us clues again and we start to figure it
out who these people are what they're
about and a puzzle is a great way to get
people to take in information pose us
something that's mysterious are curious
and right away I want to know what
what's happening what do we who are
these people and it's in a way it's like
if you want people to eat make them your
eat your dinner make sure they're hungry
you know okay get them hungry for the
information and then they're ready ready
for it ready to take it in and that
that's that's what we talk about is
information dump kind of the mirror
opposite of that would be like a screen
crawl okay this is what happened here
and here and here and
the guy key he was born here he raised
there the people won't remember that
Star Wars begins with that scream crawl
but they also it's part of the style of
it and all the information that's on
there gets repeated in various ways
during the course of the early part of
the story so it's actually more style
than it's necessary for anything else
you know you're probably not going to
remember that so that's that we do you
know talk about give examples of
different kinds of strategies that
filmmakers have use to get us interested
in these things so but often movies
begin with a puzzle successful ones so
I'm kind of visual puzzle and then we
get curious and then we want to see get
we get a little bit of information then
we get a little bit more and then
finally before we know what we're in but
the key is to smuggle the information in
in little bits preferably in the
narrative so that we don't know we're
getting that or we don't know where
we're we're not aware we're getting the
information like American Beauty let's
say taking that as an example we sort of
dissect that in terms of the the puzzle
analogy right that's been a long time
since I've seen that but that begins
with that disembodied voice he's talking
and he's he airborne soaring over the
top am I remembering it right I believe
so and then it one at some point you see
a net benning's character and she's
holding like an open house maybe right
and and she's you know she's got the
realtor face on and she's she's super
happy Pollyanna and then they shut the
door and she kind of like has a meltdown
and then you go oh wow this is really
good yes that's well that's giving you
clues he doesn't tell you what happens I
think he says in a year I'll be dead and
that's creates anticipation of course
the key and this is when we talk about
page-turner we're talking about
anticipation I'm into it I want to
anticipate what's happening I'm trying
to figure it out that's a little clue
that gets thrown out there and it makes
us wonder in fact that's something
in the first book the screenwriting the
sequence approach it's called a deadline
I mean I didn't invent that term but
it's the term that narrow colleges use a
deadline is a just but it sounds in that
movie it's exactly what it is he's going
to be dead in a year but a deadline is a
certain time limit that people are
working under characters are working
under you know I got six days to get to
X I've got to be at home by midnight or
X that's a very useful tool the deadline
but we're okay so with American Beauty
right they just give you a little clue
make us curious then you have their the
clue that suggests somebody who's happy
and then you give us a surprise twist we
learn more and then now we're curious
and the curiosity keeps propelling us in
you